there are two chamber entered the court
with her eyes down quickly turning her
back to the cameras as usual day 128 of
her trial appeared to be like any other
until the suspect indicated she could no
longer work with her lawyers but kenzie
he's an insomnia book she now has until
midday tomorrow to explain her reason I
said League night on that Saturday
long-term him after that infamous the
defense will get the chance to have
their say on the matter hind foot holes
then the court will consider whether the
alleged breakdown in confidence is
serious enough to prevent further
cooperation zama bad moogly the root of
the problem is believed to be
differences in opinion on strategy one
cause of friction has been the
court-appointed lawyers refusal to allow
chaper to speak at her trial now the
defendants request to change lawyers
threatens to derail proceedings under
German law trials may not be adjourned
for more than 30 days that may not give
new lawyers enough time to brief
themselves which could later provide
grounds for an appeal but refusing
tapers request could also give her
grounds for contesting the final verdict